(upbeat music)
- Happy Saturday bi-otches.
- Oh I cannot believe
we're already rallying.
We were out til
like 5AM yesterday.
- [Woman] Last call.
- Oh last call, you
know what that means.
- You're gonna drunk text Brian.
- Yep.
Oh my god.
- [Woman] What?
- I texted him.
I texted Brian.
- When?
- Earlier today
when I was sober.
(gasps)
I sober texted him.
This is really embarrassing.
- What did you say?
- It's pretty articulate.
Should I text him again and say
that's not who I am at all?
- Okay no.
I think you should send
him a super drunk selfie
and a wink face.
It'll balance everything out
and maybe he'll forget
about that other text.
- That's so smart.
- That's good.
Yes.
- Okay.
Sent.
Cool.
That's done.
- So Jessie, how have you been
since finding out
you were adopted?
- Not good.
- Oh my god, Brian texted.
- [Both] Oh.
- Thank god, it's a drunk
booty call text. (laughs)
We're okay.
He said to ditch my
underpamts and come over.
- I can only assume he
meant underpants (laughs).
- Okay ladies I'm out.
- Oh hey, wait, you said you
were gonna get this round.
- What?
I can't, I'm sorry
it's so loud in here.
I can't hear ...
- She left us just like
your parents left you.
(toilet flushes)
- Okay let's take
off our clothes.
- Wait.
Can we just talk about
that text you sent me?
- Wait, wait, no, Brian,
just forget about the text.
I was just rested and awake
and it just kind of came out.
- I know, I mean I get that
but some of the
stuff you said ...
I'm never gonna forget it.
It was wild.
I mean look at this.
I respect you.
Why would you say that to me?
I would like to get
to know you better
in a new context
if that's something you'd
be comfortable with.
That is the longest
sentence I've ever read.
- Listen, I promise that was
just my crazy sober brain.
I was just reacting to
the existential loneliness
that kicks in when you're not
totally numbing all of your
feelings with substance.
So it didn't mean anything.
- It doesn't mean anything.
- I don't know.
I just see you now as this
three dimensional person
with thoughts, feelings,
and parents ...
Oh my god you
probably have parents.
- Brian, no, stop, stop.
Don't ruin what we have.
Look, I see you as
just a reliably safe
and reasonably enjoyable penis.
You're basically a
piece of meat to me.
- I'm just a piece of meat?
Do you really mean that?
- Yeah.
So I want you to hear me
and believe me when I say
I don't like you enough to
ever ever actually date you.
(soft piano music)
- Aw.
Same.
Yeah let's just go
have some mediocre sex
and then I'll fall
asleep immediately.
- I would really like that.
- Oh wait,
you really do like my
paintings though right?